A FDA, que é a agência reguladora dos
Estados Unidos, acabou de retirar
aquelas advertências de risco máximo que
vinham nas caixas dos hormônios pra
menopausa. Sabe aquelas tarjas pretas
assultadoras? Pois é, elas foram
removidas. E por quê? Porque elas eram
baseadas naquele estudo famoso de 2002,
o WHI, que na época assustou o mundo
inteiro e fez milhões de mulheres
abandonarem um tratamento que poderia
estar melhorando a vida delas. A nova
avaliação mostrou que quando a terapia
hormonal é iniciada em mulheres com
menos de 60 anos ou até 10 anos depois
do início da menopausa, ela é segura e
eficaz. E olha, os benefícios vão muito
além de só aliviar os sintomas. Estamos
falando de proteção óssea, redução do
risco de diabetes tipo 2, melhora
significativa na qualidade de vida,
inclusive prevenção do Alzheimer. Claro
que cada caso é um caso e precisa de
avaliação individual, mas essa mudança
da FDA valia do que muitos de nós da
visão funcional já vínhamos dizendo há
anos. Se você está na menopausa ou se
aproximando dela, essa é uma conversa
importante para ter com quem te
acompanha.